[Music]
glass currently has critics torn across
the board and I partly think that this
is down to the film's ending throughout
this video I'll be giving my thoughts on
how to fix it and give the superhero
saga the satisfying conclusion that it
deserved I will be talking about key
moments in the film's original ending so
there will be heavy spoilers here if you
haven't seen the film and don't want to
know anything about its closing scenes
then I highly suggest that you turn off
now but for everyone else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I watch it so you don't
have to okay so in the original ending
of glass we learn that there has existed
a secret society for thousands of years
that set humanity at a constant level
playing field by stopping both good and
bad people with superhuman abilities
personally I think this twist is
laughable especially when we discover
that they've existed for thousands and
thousands of years but no one has ever
heard of them it's completely out of the
blue disconnected from split and
unbreakable and hasn't really been
hinted at in the prior movies meaning
that its inclusion in the climax doesn't
carry the emotional weight that ensured
I think this should have been scrapped
altogether and removed from the final
act instead what we should have had is
the events play out quite similar but
with a slightly different conclusion in
my other video on the film I discussed
how I think that the revelation that the
beasts father was killed on the same
train crash that caused David Dunn to
discover his abilities was a
masterstroke his killing of mr. glass
really brings the arc full circle and
makes a lot of sense however in the
original ending the Beast is then shot
and killed when Kevin grabs the light
David is then drowned in a puddle and
neither the hero or villain get a
satisfying send-off the puddle drowning
just makes no sense and whilst I get
what the director was trying to do
showing that even the strongest of us
have weaknesses it just makes for too
head-scratching deaths what would have
improved the ending in my opinion would
have been for David at some point during
the fight to wrap his arms around Kevin
similar to the
unbreakable this would make it almost
impossible for Kevin to use his arms and
hurt anyone else
Kevin similar to the villain at the end
of an breakable could then run towards a
body of water hoping that done would be
weakened by it these bodies of water
appear throughout the film so it's not
like they're exactly hard to find both
were become submerged in the water and
done would be given a choice he could
either let go of the Beast and allow him
to escape in the hopes of eventually
catching up with him at some point or
realize that he is the only one that can
stop him and decide to not let go
drowning both of them in the process
this choice or rather sacrifice would
stop the beast from continuing his
rampage and would also give Duns death
weight and consequences to it in my
opinion in the final cut of the film
Dunn's death is in vain and seems like a
bad way for the character to go out
whereas this would show that he really
was the best of us willing to give it
all up in order to stop evil this would
still allow the world to accept that
superhumans exist without the secret
society nonsense and makes for a much
better arc for the character obviously
I'd love to hear your thoughts on my
ending and if you have an even better
one if you've got another final scene in
your head then make sure you leave it in
the comments below as I'd love to read
it if you enjoyed this video then please
like it and make sure you check out my
original ending explain breakdown and
spoiler talk review on the film which
will be linked at the end this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks for
taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]